3 es avec nous pour le match des idées
ce soir thierry fabre bienvenue
rédacteur en chef à challenge je montre
la une ne laissons pas la crise nous
abattre la voile à la une
benjamin coriat et également avec mon
bienvenue benjamin moreau fester
j'économise l'université paris 13
membres des économistes atterrés et
auteur de ce livre la pandémie
l'anthropocène et le bien commun vous
avez fait une explication de texte la
semaine dernière je vais pas vous faire
répéter un projet de loi de finances
c'est plein de sujets on va se
concentrer sur deux grandes idées
maîtresses du budget sorties du sénat
première idée thierry fabre faire payer
les grands gagnants du confinement c'est
l'une des idées maîtresses et notamment
les entreprises du e-commerce
qu'en pensez vous alors écoutez dans une
période difficile comme celle là où le
l'économie étant des diminutions
l'arrestation de plus de 10 %
pensez à taxer les entreprises je pense
pas que ce soit le bon moment
c'est-à-dire il ya effectivement des
entreprises dans les secteurs se porte
encore bien et notamment le e-commerce
alors que pour le reste c'est plutôt
l'effondrement est ce qu'il faut à ce
moment là alors que globalement
l'économie est en récession les taxes et
je pense pas je pense que les la bonne
stratégie c'est d'attendre que
l'économie reparte vraiment en attend un
redémarrage en deux ans en 2021 donc
autour de 6% dans ce sens quand même en
dessous du niveau
donc voilà toute taxe tout prélèvement
sur les entreprises ou sur les ménages
en fait ça peut casser la croissance
ça a été le cas après la crise
financière on avait prélevé notamment
sur les ménages mais aussi sur les
entreprises parce qu'il y avait il
fallait réduire le déficit
ça a cassé la croissance dans toute
l'europe donc je pense que c'est pas le
bon moment
vous savez les profiteurs de la crise
simplement oui des gens ou le e-commerce
à une bonne augmentation de son chiffre
d'affaires hilary la récupère mais enfin
c'est je veux dire il faut il faut mieux
laisser l'entraînement du pour le reste
de l'économie plutôt que de stopper
brutalement sais pas pourquoi j'aime ça
vous n'avez pas être d'accord non bien
sûr je vais pas être d'accord j'aurais
j'entends un j'entends ce qui est dit
mais en même temps on est quand même
dans une situation dans laquelle
les entreprises a fait de l'économie en
général et les entreprises sont
absolument sous perfusion non ça me font
et je dis pas que c'est malin parce que
sinon tout se serait effondré tant
qu'elles sont sous perfusion donc il ya
un flot d'argent qui va vers les
entreprises en partie vers leurs
salariés et c'est une bonne chose
on va sans doute encore parlé tout à
l'heure bon on ne peut pas comment dire
faire un flot indifférenciée même pour
celles qui vont bien et qui vont très
bien je veux dire c'est absolument doit
taxer celles qui vont bien oui pour la
réponse et vous visionnez la réponse est
oui on a eu ce débat la semaine dernière
sur les assurés auraient venir dans dix
ans il faut que les assureurs
contribuent parce que c'est des
bénéficiaires ne veut pas employer
l'expression profiteurs de la crise
parce que je veux dire c'est autre chose
dit dédé profiteurs de guerre etc c'est
autre chose dit pas que c'est des
profiteurs mais c'est des bénéficiaires
tout à fait incontestable et donc moi je
serais pas choqué du tout je trouverais
normal que des entreprises dont comment
dire les revenus les profits etc sont
significativement augmenté ce qui est le
cas du e-commerce par exemple
contribuent un tout petit peu au
maintien à flot de l'ensemble de
l'économie
moi je trouverais ça normal et c'est
vrai que parmi ces gagnants du
confinement n'en a parlé la semaine
dernière ses assureurs et c'est parce
que les sénateurs ont voté lui l'idée
d'une taxe exceptionnelle que bruno le
maire a puis ça a pu s'appuyer but suez
négocié à la dure hier et faire plier
les assureurs pour qu'il gèle
ils ont gelé les primes c'était une
belle opération
j'ai pas si ça a été fait exprès mais ça
y ressemble utiliser le le le pouvoir la
taxe la pression pour justement que les
assureurs
enfin fasse preuve d'un peu de
solidarité pour le coup ça a marché mais
ça c'est différent c'était un secteur
effectivement le sentiment qu'il ya eu à
la fois des profits exceptionnels
beaucoup moins de sinistralité donc mai
ils ont traîné les pieds pour justement
faire face faire preuve de solidarité
avec leurs clients donc là il ya une
pression mérité méritait qu'on peut leur
mettre sur les épaules parce que pour le
reste donc moi je suis pas d'accord pour
taxer en revanche il faut faire
attention à ce que des entreprises ne
bénéficient pas de façon abusive des
dispositifs mais c'est pas pareil c'est
à dire une entreprise qui va bien mais
qui me fait appel au pkk aucun
dispositif et d'autres dispositifs de
l'état bon
dont acte en revanche une entreprise qui
comme vivendi à vue a augmenté ses
dividendes et à utiliser pour une de ses
filiales en l'occurrence canal+ le
chômage partiel l'an se dit il ya un
truc qui m'a pas vraiment quand on voit
dans la téléphonie a eu des entreprises
comme sfr qui ont utilisé le chômage
partiel mais orange et free ne l'a pas
fait
pourquoi dans la distribution carrefour
l'a utilisé et d'autre les mutualistes
non utilisé beaucoup moins donc on voit
bien qu'à comme une aide de l'état
massive et il faut faire attention à ce
que ça ne soit pas abusivement utile
parce que ça peut même faire dans le si
c'est l'économie actuelle une distorsion
de concurrence vers des petits malins
qui peuvent bénéficier des aides et
d'autres pas et ça peut faire perdre en
terme d'image c'est ce qui s'est passé
pour les assureurs le monde il ya même
consacré son édito du jour intitulé
ainsi qu'aux vite 19 des assureurs en
mêle de prévoyance mis au pied du mur
par le gouvernement les compagnies ont
finalement consenti à geler les
cotisations d'assurance multirisque
professionnelle
mais pour restaurer leur image qui a été
écornée ils doivent aller encore plus
loin leur image est écornée certes mais
les assureurs on en a besoin de toute
façon ils continueront comme ça ben
c'est pas sûr qu'ils continuent comme ça
parce que si vous voulez il n'ya pas de
secteur plus réglementée que l'assurance
ou la banque
donc ils continueront dans les marges
qu'on leur laisse
elles sont déjà extrêmement demande donc
je veux dire qu'on fasse bouger la
réglementation de manière transitoire ou
de manière plus durable en fonction des
circonstances c'est dans l'ordre des
choses
c'est dans l'ordre des choses donc elles
continueront comme ça la réponse est non
elles continueront comme si on les
laisse continuer comme ça et donc là
effectivement il ya une pression exercée
et on a réussi à bouger
alors pour aller dans l'esprit de ce qui
a été dit c'est vrai qu' on va
certainement reparler mais ça fait
partie du budget là on est dans un à loi
rectificative mais dans le budget
proprement dit le dégrèvement massif de
deux fois 10 milliards d'euros prévus
dans le plan de laurence dans le plan de
relance et qui va bénéficier
principalement aux grandes entreprises
parce qu'en fait on la calcule et c'est
plutôt les entreprises de plus de 250
mille euros bon vraiment ça se discute
vraiment ça se discute est ce qu'on a
besoin de donner encore davantage en
tout cas à y compris à la tranche des
entreprises qui vont le mieux
vraiment moi je moi je ma réponse est
non
ma réponse est non il faut faire
différemment donc c'est déséquilibré oui
enfin simplement après faut savoir de
quoi on parle on parle d'entreprises
industrielles et on a pris conscience
après l'es7 crise qu'il y avait un
problème de relocalisation de
délocalisation massive d'une partie nous
industrie où on est on a des taxes
locales très supérieurs notamment à nos
voisins allemands donc je veux savoir ce
qu'on joue et c'est à dire que baisser
ce genre de taxe ces deux fait un outil
pour essayer de maintenir une partie
notre industrie sur notre centre
ce n'est pas le seul facteur à dire que
en quête de patrick artus économiste qui
met les idées en place en dix ans
l'industrie française elle a certes une
fiscalité supérieur mais c'est pas ça
qui va vraiment faire la différence
anduze et l'investissement dans la
matière grise et la numérisation d aider
donc on est on est d'accord mais
n'empêche avoir un petit boulet ou en
gros boulet fiscal au pied mais ça peut
expliquer dans une partie des
délocalisations mais écoutez fin on si
on aborde le sujet on aborde le sujet
c'est pratiquement la dernière chose
qu'ils restaient dans la liste des deux
mondes du medef vie
à vis du gouvernement parce qu'il ya un
lobbying extrêmement bien organisée et
qui suit une liste alors yare la
question de l'impôt sur les sociétés y
avait la question c'est un peu différent
mais du est-ce que ça touche les les
fortunes personnelles mais on voit bien
que c'est pas très différent un camp les
fortunes contenus personnels sont
constitués par des actions donc il y
avait ça etc etc
bon le la flexibilité du travail on va
en reparler certainement tout à l'heure
donc je veux dire c'est à chaque fois
c'est le truc d'après qui manquent pour
la compétitivité
faut arrêter de se moquer du monde nous
ne cessons de perdre des emplois
en même temps que nous avons un nombre
d'entreprises au sein du cac40
internationalisé parmi les mails enfin
en tout cas dans les pays de notre
taille il ya aucun pays qui a autant
d'entreprises mondiales et
internationalisé qui est donc le
problème est d ailleurs voilà deuxième
idée maîtresse à retenir du plf du
projet de loi de finances fraîchement
votée au sénat donc c'est le volet
fiscalité écologique est là on est dans
un entre deux le sénat vote d'un côté la
réduction de la tva sur les billets
train ce qui semble plutôt une mesure
écolo d'un autre côté il supprime
provisoirement la création d'un nouveau
malus sur le poids des véhicules qui
seraient en contradiction avec le plan
de soutien à la filière automobile
annoncé par le président de la
république
on sent que la philosophie générale du
sénat c'est de faire une transition
écolo qui soit acceptée socialement
est ce que le sénat raison de son
soucier après l'épisode et gilet jaune
est ce qu'une fiscalité écologique ne
peut être acceptable que si elle les
douces enfin si elle est douce et de
plus ou moins douce et plus ou moins
bien expliquer à la population
il faut bien voir l'échec de la taxe
carbone doit renvoyer à ce que d'autres
pays ont fait et ont réussi les
champions du monde de la taxe carbone ce
sont les suédois
ils ont réussi depuis 1990 à mettre en
panne en place une taxe qui a été
expliquée mais qui est très importante
et qui a eu un effet massif sur les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre en
france a été très mal fait on l'épisode
aider gilet jaune alors ensuite là ce
dont vous parlez c'est un petit peu du
bricolage c'est à dire
plus taxer les véhicules lourds certes
mais si on tâte les véhicules lourds ça
va de fait défavorisés en partie
l'industrie automobile française disent
les constructeurs donc est ce qu'on le
fait vraiment mais franchement c'est du
bricolage c'est pas du tout à l'échelle
d'une vraie fiscalité écologique qui a
été fait dans certains pays on avait
pris la loi en fait la taxe carbone qui
a créé les gilet jaune c'était la bonne
taxe mais qui a été appliquée de façon
bête et méchante et surtout qui a pas
pris en compte l'impact pour les revenus
modestes ne regardait des économistes
ont bien documenté le fait que
effectivement c'est les plus modestes
qui paient plus non non moi je voudrais
remettre les pendules à l'heure
lorsqu'on parle de taxe carbone et de
gilet jaune
on est totalement à côté de la plaque
c'est une taxe qui a porté sur l'essence
à 1
le centre diesel enfin bref les
combustibles
or il se trouve que c'est déjà hyper
taxer et que de fait les gilet jaune
pour parler vite ou en tout cas les
automobilistes paient une taxe carbone
qui est 10 fois le 12 fois vingt fois
celle que payent les entreprises qui
elles pratiquement ne la paie pas au
beau grâce à un marché commun entre
guillemets artificielle des changes de
taxe carbone
bon donc c'est pas du tout une taxe
carbone c'était une taxe sur l'essence
et les véhicules industriels
une véritable taxe carbone qui serait
distribué justement sur les émetteurs
véritable de co2 et qui équilibre risque
est déjà payée sur l'essence par rapport
à ce qui est payé dans tout reste et je
pense malheureusement au bâtiment je
pense à l'agriculture je pense à toute
une série d'entreprises qui émet des gaz
à effet de serre très considérable donc
je veux dire je suis absolument me may
hamm séville 0-0 contre l'idée que c'est
la taxe carbone qui a échoué est pas du
tout c'est une taxe supplémentaire
encore plus importante sur une toute
petite fraction de gens qui sont les
automobilistes et parmi ceux-ci en plus
ceux des périphéries de l'élégie
les jaunes en tout cas avait de la taxe
carbone elle est entièrement neuf elle
n'a pas encore été expérimenté enfin en
tout cas protéger la planète vous serez
tous d'accord là dessus c'est réduire
les émissions de co2 et pour emmanuel
macron ça passe par le nucléaire après
son plaidoyer de pour le nucléaire dans
une interview à brut
le chef de l'état a remis ça cette après
midi c'était lors d'une visite sur le
site de framatome au creusot notre
avenir énergétique et écologique passe
par le nucléaire a dit le chef de l'état
pour en parler avec nous ce soir
matthieu auzanneau qu'on accueille dans
ce match des idées bienvenus vous
dirigez le shift projects un think tank
qui travaille sur la transition
énergétique
emmanuel macron promeut donc le
nucléaire comme atout pour réduire les
émissions de co2 et greenpeace lui a
répondu ceci cet après-midi miser sur le
nucléaire dans la course climatique
c'est miser sur un cheval
perpétuellement en retard vieillissant
et vulnérables il prouve ainsi sa
méconnaissance de l'état réel de la
filière nucléaire et de ses capacités
qu'en pensez vous en retard en termes
décarbonation pour produire de
l'électricité sans émettre de co2 il ya
essentiellement aujourd'hui dans le
monde le nucléaire et les barrages
hydroélectriques donc dire que le
nucléaire est en retard c'est c c'est
curieux il est difficile de boucler
l'équation de la décarbonation de la
production électrique sans nucléaire
c'est pas une manière de dire qu'on peut
pas faire simple c'est que c'est
très manifestement beaucoup plus
compliqué l'allemagne aujourd'hui a
décidé de sortir du nucléaire
et là beaucoup difficulté à a diminué
significativement les émissions de co2
de son système de production électrique
voilà ce que je te répond de manière un
peu équilibré vous la trouvez clair la
ligne de l'exécutif sur le nucléaire il
ferme à la fois fessenheim mais il
promeut le nucléaire c'est c'est quoi
c'est en même temps là aussi sur le
nucléaire comme envoyer cela c'est
jugement de salomon qui a été prononcée
par par françois hollande 50 % 50%
nucléaire et 50 % d'autres sources de
production électrique des gabonais
aujourd'hui l'essentiel du mix
électrique demeure produit par du
nucléaire ce qui fait que les émissions
du système électrique français sont
parmi les plus le plus cher du monde
la fermeture du ch de fessenheim pour
l'instant a tendance à compliquer
l'équation on a recours plus que
d'habitude au central c'est ce qu'on
appelle être à l'affût celles qui
marchent soit au gaz naturel soit au
charbo et on comprend que au cours de
l'hiver il risquerait d'avoir des
tensions sur le sur les réseaux du ch
est du chef de l' affaire sous fermeture
en tout cas la réduction du recours
la production nucléaire voilà c'est le
site c'est un indice c'est un symptôme
du fait que compliquer l'équation
[Musique]
en haut
quel coin qu'on pense d'eux nucléaire
par ailleurs on ne peut pour ne pas être
anti nucléaire au nom du climat il ya
plein de raisons d'être d'être hostile
au nucléaire mais c'est sûr que du point
de vue strictement du problème des
émissions de co2 le nucléaire ne fait
pas partie des
des sources d'émission de mathieu than
oo je vous propose de rester avec nous
je vais faire réagir évidemment nos
invités en plateau et vous fait signe si
vous souhaitez réagir à ce qui est dit
thierry fabre en arabe sont
effectivement d'une voie médiane sur le
nucléaire d' emmanuel macron est-ce que
c'est lisible est ce que c'est clair
c'est un entre eux deux c'est un peu de
nucléaire mais pas trop alors c'est
effectivement pas très lisible et là le
en même temps ne fonctionne pas vraiment
mais je rebondis sur ce que vient de
dire monsieur aux anneaux c'est vraiment
important de remettre les choses en
place par rapport au communiqué de
greenpeace qui dit scandale le nucléaire
ne permettra pas de baisser le gaz à
effet de serre mais c'est juste linverse
dire qu'on voit bien ce qui se passe
avec la fermeture de fessenheim tous les
experts et pas seulement les experts
pro-nucléaire vous disent que c'est
plusieurs millions de tonnes de co2 qui
seront émises en plus parce qu'il faille
il va falloir compenser par du charbon
c'est exactement ce qui vient d'être dit
c'est à dire c'est sympa de dire le
nucléaire a plein de défauts il est
dangereux il peut être dangereux et il
est cher très bien mais sauf que si on
ferme
si on compense par du part du charbon
c'est catastrophique et donc il faut
quand même avoir la cette personne afin
mieux mais les écologistes vont vous
dire qu on a peut-être mieux qu'on a
mise à marché en baisse
c'est vraiment il faut organiser la
transition mais il faut faire être
capable d'organiser une transition qui
fasse que si on ferme une centrale on
augmente on ne pollue pas plus
simplement dire que l'exemple de
fessenheim montre qu'on va polluer plus
je trouve ça catastrophique ça c'est pas
pour autant qu'il faut être tout
nucléaire mais il faut organiser une
transition intelligente et elle a
visiblement elle n'est pas organisée
benjamin coriat alors plusieurs choses
bon d'abord il est exact que la filière
nucléaire
si on raisonne en termes de gaz à effet
de serre et moins polluante que voilà le
charbon ou d'autres ou de gaz ou
d'autres ressources ou d'autres
ressources fossiles
encore que le bilan complet des gaz à
effet de serre de l'ensemble de la
filière y compris l'extraction d'uranium
les transports etc devra être c'est
devra être fait c'est pas pour dire que
ça l'est davantage mais je dis faut
cesser de croire qu' il n'y a pas
d'émission de gaz à effet de serre dans
la filière nucléaire
bon ça c'est mes et matthieu auzanneau
voudra réagir je vous laisserai réagir
matthews et oui c'est promis ok donc ça
c'est mon premier point mon second point
c'est que par rapport à ce que vous
dites bien sûr que si on arrête des
centrales et il va falloir les arrêter
parce que il n'ya pas tegaz à effet de
serre il ya aussi les déchets dont on ne
sait absolument pas quoi faire
aujourd'hui en france on est en train de
se passer la patate chaude pour savoir
qui veut bien prendre les essais
nucléaires
personne ne veut personne ne sait où on
est on est pratiquement à saturation des
capacités et ça c'est des choses qui
vont durer quelques millénaires où
quelques dizaines de millénaires
alors j'ai dit on ad'autres qu'est ce
qu'on a de mieux alors l'autre point
c'est que oui il ya un coût en termes de
gaz à effet de serre de l'abandon du
nucléaire mais il ya un coup parce que
on n'a rien préparé et qu'on est d'une
modestie d'une prudence de et c'est sur
les énergies alternatives qui n'avait
ainsi pas assez évidemment ça fait 20
ans qu'on dit je voudrais rajouter une
dernière chose puisqu'en ce moment on
débat de la convention citoyenne sur le
climat et ou maquereau est en train
passez moi l'expression à de se couvrir
de ridicule
après avoir installé cette commission
après avoir dit sans filtre machin etc
il est en train de tout découdre et
qu'est-ce qui lé coût des mesures
essentielles qui concerne non pas
l'augmentation de la consommation
d'électricité
mais précisément sa diminution c'est à
dire les passoires thermiques etc
il veut découdre ces mesures là parce
que l'autre question c'est
pas seulement d'augmenter la
consommation électrique c ou électriques
ou 2 ou 2 ou énergétique mais de de
baisser la consommation folie découdre
c'est dans le plan de relance à
plusieurs milliards qui sont prévues là
dedans non non pas du tout pas du tout
il est en train de découvrir entièrement
les 150 les 149 propositions de la
convention citoyenne qui a attendu
patiemment non le l'analyse du de
l'impact carbone complet du nucléaire ne
va pas être faite elle a été fait de
nombreuses fois
si on la rapporte à la production
électrique
le nucléaire est maire à peu près autant
que c'est comparable c'est du même ordre
de grandeur que l'éolien le solaire et
mais plus la fabrication des panneaux
solaires est très énergivore et
réclament les énergies carbonées
aujourd'hui c'est bien pour ça qu'elle
est à cher d'ailleurs c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles n'est pas cher
or donc ce point là et ce point là est
parfaitement documenté l'alternative
c'est toujours la même chose c'est
recourir fondamentalement aux l'éolien
et au solaire
lorsqu'il n'y a pas de vent et pas assez
de soleil
la solution la plus simple c'est de
recourir à des centrales qui s'allume et
qui s'était facilement nous des
centrales des centrales à feu on
alimente pour l'instant avec du
principalement
avec du gaz naturel ça avait du sérieux
donc il faut raisonner de manière
systémique il faut raisonner site de
manière systémique sur l'électricité
qu'elle est lequel est le meilleur
quelques élus meilleurs de meilleures
technologies pour avoir les émissions
minimale dans ce cadre là l'avantagé
quand même plus tôt aujourd'hui
plus tôt aujourd'hui au nucléaire il ya
d'autres encore une fois il ya d'autres
raisons d'être anti nucléaires mais la
raison carbone et papa pas une très très
bonne raison et puis surtout et là je
rejoins ce qui a été dit il faut avoir
une approche systémique les besoins en
énergie peuvent doivent et peuvent être
réduits mais là le problème c'est que la
république mais pas forcément l'argent
l'argent là où il le faut
aujourd'hui typiquement on met beaucoup
d'argent notamment dans les panneaux
solaire et l'éolien on pourrait
peut-être en mettre davantage sur
l'évolution de la mobilité sur les
infrastructures qui permettent vous
parlez la taxe carbone tout à l'heure
qui permette aux gens qui habitent en
périphérie urbaine de se déplacer
autrement que en ayant recours à
à l'automobile il ya beaucoup de
solutions mais il faut que la république
un débat patients et c'est ce que
propose la convention citoyenne pour le
climat mais à mon avis à mon humble avis
avis il faut dépasser cet arbre qui
cache la forêt qui est perpétuellement
où les deux arbres que son nucléaire
versus renouvelables qui cache la forêt
d'un problème qui est beaucoup plus
vaste est beaucoup plus profond que
c'était la forêt la transition pour ce
sujet là merci infiniment matthieu
auzanneau d'avoir participé de manière
brève à ce match des idées on organisera
évidemment un débat sur ce point parce
que ça ça passionne et c'est passionnant
troisième thème de ce match
on en parlait déjà la semaine dernière
si cette série de plans de licenciements
qui tombe depuis septembre et qui
pourrait encore tomber à partir de
janvier
la faute aux délocalisations qui se
poursuivent nous dit fabien roussel le
patron du pcf qui était l'invitée
d'auditions publiques sur notre antenne
hier soir garantir à tout le monde qui
conserve son travail et que l'on puisse
continuer de travailler
donc on met un moratoire sur les plans
de licenciements qui tombe en ce moment
et qui ne sont pas acceptables mettez
vous à la place de ces familles ils vont
pas s'interroger si ils vont manger à 6
le soir de noël
ils vont s'interroger sur est ce qu'on
va pouvoir fêter noël parce qu'on perd
notre emploi est-ce qu'on va devoir
déménager parce que l'usiné ferme
enfin vous vous imaginez ce qui leur
tombe sur la tête à ces dizaines de
milliers de familles qui sont
aujourd'hui licencié parce que leur
entreprise délocalise sa délocalisent
encore à tout va dans notre pays
thierry fabre un moratoire sur les
licenciements c'est réaliste et faisable
c'est souhaitable c'est un peu la même
chose que sujet précédent c'est-à-dire
le côté il ya un côté que théologique
dans cette affaire là c'est à dire qu'on
ya une religion il faut empêcher les
grands groupes de licenciés c'est mal
mais juste il faut se demander ce que ça
coûte combien de gens ça concerne et
j'ai vérifié des chiffres avant de venir
ces licenciements des grands groupes
c'est 2 à 3 % des entrées au chômage
c'est donc quelques dizaines de milliers
d'emplois sur 700 17 mille emplois qui
ont été détruits exactement depuis le
début de
donc c'est on peut discuter à l'envi de
stratégies des grands groupes
ce n'est pas toujours très éthique mais
simplement on ne traite pas le problème
un moratoire sans doute ça ne réglera
pas le problème du chômage cela
donnerait une image de la france en
disant qu'ils traitent collectiviste une
certaine manière mais ça ne réglerait
pas le problème qui est que la plupart
des fans contrats sont des fins de cdd
c'est à dire quand il ya les entreprises
ont chuté des peines de deux cdd de 46%
depuis le début de l'année donc
simplement c c'est cette masse d'emploi
qui est en train de disparaître qu'il
faut traiter deux fois arrêter de parler
de bridgestone qui est un problème grave
pour les familles concernées je ne nie
pas que localement c'est une catastrophe
mais à l'échelle du marché de l'emploi
du pays c'est juste minoritaire donc
faux faux plus essayer de parler des
solutions a lancé pour redémarrer de
l'emploi en france de se polariser sur
les plans sociaux de quelques grands
comptes et nous dit que ça continue de
délocaliser à tout-va aussi en benjamin
koré ben oui malheureusement bien sûr ça
continue de délocaliser parce que la
dynamique qui est la nôtre dont on
parlait tout à l'heure je veux dire à la
quantité il répète un parce que c'est
vraiment très important
la quantité de grands groupes
internationalisés qui sont dans les
trois ou quatre plus grands mondiaux
qu'on a en france personne la perceuse à
l'allemagne l'a pas l'italie on n'en
parle même pas une bonne nouvelle
bah c'était c'est une nouvelle avec des
effets
des deux côtés parce que d'un côté les
entreprises vont très bien mais de
l'autre côté l'emploi en france va très
mal
vous avez pour ces grands groupes plus
d'emplois en france rapporté à leurs
activités du tout quand le siège est en
france mais on avait quand même une
propos le siège est souvent pas en
france le siège il est souvent en
hollande ou dans des endroits dans
lequel les conditions fiscales
permettent de ne pas payer d'impôts bon
mais revenons revenons à notre sujet
sujet notre sujet c'est pour nous on va
être d'accord on va être d'accord d'une
certaine manière bien entendu la
question de dire moratoire sur les
licenciements comme tel bon ça peut
paraître un peu comment dire
venu de nulle part mais comment dire moi
je voudrais un moratoire beaucoup plus
générale je devrais un moratoire
beaucoup plus je m'explique je
m'explique
c'est vrai qu'il ya des fins de cdd mais
il ya aussi toute une série de deux
d'accord collectif de licenciement il ya
toute une série de plans de départs
volontaires
bref on a mis en place pendant la
période d'avant si je peux dire toute
une série de dispositifs pour faciliter
le passage chômage et du coup maintenant
hop on s'en sert en masse en période
difficile et c'est donc il ya très peu
moi ce que j'aimerais moi ce que j'aime
non mais c'est de rentrer dans le détail
non non il faudrait rentrer dans les
tailles janvier ce que tu en janvier moi
ce que j'aimerais
on sait ce que j'aimerais moi ce que
j'aimerais c'est que on repasse au
crible l'ensemble de ces dispositifs et
que le moratoire ils sont bien plus
générale je suis pas de ceux qui pensent
que une entreprise ne doit pas bouger
au contraire je pense que les
entreprises voient beaucoup plus
investir sur le futur et la transition
écologique qu'elle ne le font
aujourd'hui donc moi je suis pour
prononcer la phrase terrible étrangers
pour vous dire que les licenciements
économiques pour l'instant c'est quasi
inexistant les fans contrats se font
différemment donc effectivement on
pourra rien faire en se polarisant sur
ces licenciements économiques journée ou
d'un pardon on le redoute pour janvier
où pranger il y aura une vague de plans
sociaux actuellement n'oublions pas que
pour l'instant l'état en investissant en
dépensant 23 24 milliards dans le
chômage partiel à éviter ça c'est à dire
le flou et à éviter ces licenciements
économiques
en revanche il n'a pas pu éviter la fin
des cdd de l'intérim parce que ça et ces
gens là qui sont retrouvés sur le
carreau
donc c'est ces gens là qu'il faut
traiter pour essayer de relancer la
machine économique et ne plus se
focaliser sur sur des grands groupes qui
les kick ass l'arbre qui cache vraiment
la force et je vous promets de vous
laissez plus que 35 noeuds pour conclure
la la semaine prochaine ou la prochaine
fois merci infiniment en tout cas tous
les deux d'avoir participé fin de cette
émission on se retrouve demain à 18
heures et à 22h30 en attendant vous
retrouverez bonjour chez vous dès 7h30
au rayonnement de chimie recevra
aurélien pradié députés aient l'air du
lot je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée sur public sénat